j'ouvre tout de suite notre second débat
il nous emmène à Marseille à Marseille
dans les quartiers nord ou les
règlements de comptes se succèdent
depuis le début de l'année des victimes
de plus en plus jeunes des tueurs à gaz
de 18 ans à peine une guerre des gangs
sur fond de trafic de drogue les
habitants se sentent pris en otage Samia
dechir et Adriana
ces deux femmes merci toutes deux perdus
un proche sous les balles des
trafiquants de drogue
Ryan le neveu de Laetitia avec 14 ans
lorsqu'il a été tué le 18 août 2021 au
marronniers un quartier nord de
Marseille il est sorti donc un soir
d'été il devait aller manger un bout
avec un de ses amis et dormir son
meilleur ami et en sortant du quartier
une moto est arrivée avec deux personnes
dessus ils ont fait feu
Ryan est décédé peu de temps après il
s'est pris une rafale de
kalachnikov
son ami lui a été blessé à la jambe et
un petit de 8 ans qui était le papa
assez pris en ricochet de balle dans la
tête
donc moins d'une heure après les coups
de feu Ryan a été déclaré à mort Karima
elle a perdu son frère en 2016 l'enquête
n'a jamais abouti depuis cet avocate a
fondé un collectif qui milite pour que
ces crimes ne restent pas un puni à
partir du moment où certains assass ou
en tout cas un bon nombre d'assassinats
restent non élucidés se crée forcément
un sentiment d'impunité c'est qu'on se
dit qu'on peut aller à Marseille
assassiner aujourd'hui et pas craindre
la prison tout simplement donc oui on a
des personnes qui qui sont impliquées
sur plusieurs assassinats avant d'être
interpellés ce qui est quand même
dramatique un quelques minutes du
centre-ville le quartier de la Busserine
la zone est verrouillée par les
trafiquants impossible de s'y promener
avec une caméra elle abri des regards
c'est au centre social que nous partons
à la rencontre des habitants
Naïma Dounia et Reda sont animateurs
très attachés au quartier voisin où ils
ont grandi ils ne s'y sentent plus en
sécurité rien qu'hier on a eu trois
morts du quartier et voir les mamans qui
sont en pleurs c'est choquant quand même
et de voir que les gens ils enlèvent la
vie des gens sans penser aux
conséquences ben ça fait peur quand même
c'est devenu comme un jeu on a
l'impression que c'est devenu même banal
là on va sortir on va dire ben ça se
fait
mère de quatre enfants Fadela n'osent
plus les laisser sortir le soir pour se
rendre à l'aide aux devoirs comme
d'autres parents qu'elle rencontre
régulièrement dans un groupe de veille
elle se sent prise en otage maintenant
le regard même plus où il vise donc on
peut être visé comme la dame qui s'est
fait tirer dessus alors qu'elle était en
bas de chez elle avec sa fille le
retraité de 63 ans qui s'est fait tirer
dessus dans mon quartier à la boucherie
il y a plus de cible donc en fait quand
on déambule plus comme on le faisait on
ne marche plus on va à un point A à un
point B quand c'est nécessaire c'est une
prison un ciel ouvert en fait comment
faire reculer le trafic dans les
quartiers nord tout le monde semble
s'accorder sur un point une solution
policière ne suffira pas à ses namou a
grandi à la Savine avec son collectif il
réclame l'ouverture d'une commission
d'enquête parlementaire
sur ce sujet là en moins de 24 heures on
a eu 12 800 signataires et qui ont
réclamé avec nous cette commission
d'enquête parlementaires et en fait pour
que les collectifs visités puissent bien
agir sur un territoire l'état on a
besoin des données on a besoin de
travailler on a besoin d'écouter on a
besoin de croiser connaître le nombre de
victimes touchés par balle qui ne sont
pas forcément mortes mais qui arrivent à
l'hôpital le profil de certains jeunes
qui vont traverser les régions pour
atterrir dans nos quartiers gilets
depuis le début de l'année le trafic de
drogue a fait au moins 23 morts à
Marseille
comment sortir Marseille et ses
quartiers nord de cette spirale de
violence on en débat tout de suite avec
Stéphane Le Olivier bonsoir bien vous
êtes sénateur LR des Bouches-du-Rhône
Jean Viard bonsoir bienvenue sociologue
ancien vice-président de Marseille
Provence Métropole et hauteur de ce
livre Marseille le réveil violent d'une
ville impossible publiée aux Éditions de
l'Aube Frédéric Lequin bonsoir bienvenue
à vous aussi journaliste investigations
spécialiste de la police du banditisme
du renseignement et vous publiez avec
Christine Imbert ce livre Jacky le Matt
grande figure du banditisme marseillais
c'est aux éditions plomb on est
également au téléphone avec Fadela widev
qui est habitante des quartiers
j'espère qu'on aura une image mais de
toute façon on vous donnera la parole et
puis Émilie s'appelle ski évidemment est
resté à mes côtés éditorialiste pour
sens public
on a entendu ce chiffre à la fin du du
reportage à l'instant 23 morts dans des
règlements de compte depuis le début de
l'année à Marseille par comparaison avec
20 2 pour toute l'année 2022 il y avait
eu 37 morts sur sur le territoire
marseillais Stéphane Le rudié on parle
d'une guerre de territoire une guerre
entre trafiquants est-ce que on pouvait
voir venir ce cette flambée là de
règlement de compte
étant donné que il faut le dire l'état a
quand même lit des moyens policiers et
300 gendarmes et policiers
supplémentaires trois compagnies de CRS
avec un mot d'ordre
déstabilisé les réseaux et effectivement
quand on s'en prend au vendeur
voire même on essaye de remonter les
filières forcément le climat se tend et
véritablement les territoires coûtent de
plus en plus cher d'où cette
reconnaissance de violence et c'est pour
ça que je dirais effectivement cette
édit dans le reportage les moyens ont
été mis policiers mais ça ne suffira pas
soyons objectifs regardons la chaîne
pénale également
concernant les consommateurs
rien n'est fait sur les consommateurs on
a une amende forfaitaire délictuelle de
250 euros mais c'est pas du tout
dissuasif en cas de récidive que fait-on
est-ce qu'il y a une obligation de soin
du consommateur il faut couper le
robinet et pour couper le robinet c'est
à travers des consommateurs et je dirais
même que les consommateurs pour moi ont
même du sang dans les mains et je pèse
mes mots et oui parce qu'en consommant
on alimente le trafic et derrière les
règlements de compte si à plus de
consommateurs il y a plus de dealer donc
je dis attention il y a les forces de
l'ordre qui sont présents il y a une
défaillance de la chaîne pénale on peut
parler des peines elles sont pas
suffisantes notamment au niveau des
têtes de réseau dès lors qu'on les
attrape et derrière il faut travailler
sur les consommateurs faut également
faire des grosses campagnes
d'information chose qu'on a faites pour
la sécurité routière qu'on a jamais
faite pour pour la drogue on va en
reparler plus tard sur les consommateurs
mais je voudrais vous entendre là-dessus
janvier parce que il y a vraiment
l'argument complètement inverse qui
consiste à dire il faut peut-être au
contraire essayer ce qu'on a pas essayé
depuis toujours en France c'est-à-dire
plutôt légalisé ou dépénaliser
la consommation de
de hachis quoi en gros on estime qu'il y
a 150 à 200000 gens qui travaillent dans
le l'herbe cette droglace pas des autres
pour peu près 3 milliards c'est de ça
dont on parle mettez-vous dans les
quartiers nord de Marseille le revenu
moyen des gens le taux de chômage femme
seule avec enfant etc il y a un moment
comme vous avez énormément d'argent
comme ça il faut dire l'état a perdu
c'est triste moi attendez je préférerais
que l'État ait gagné mais le résultat
c'est que la France on fait une énorme
répression on a une énorme consommation
et autour de nous quelle politique on
mène on n'est pas une île c'est un peu
comme ça la prostitution ça c'est très
bien de faire des règles mais les autres
l'Allemagne ils sont en train de
légaliser la Californie est autorisée le
Portugal a fait des trucs très
intéressants pour diminuer la
consommation le Canada aussi et ils
arrivent à diminuer la consommation et
l'objectif c'est diminuer la
consommation donc je pense si vous
voulez qu'on est à un moment il faut
dire la prohibition ça ne marche pas
après ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
légaliser n'importe comment etc mais il
faut réduire etc il faut faire des
travail vis-à-vis des jeunes dans les
écoles attention à la drogue ça abîme le
cerveau attention ça va être en
impuissant quand tu es ado et cetera il
y a tout un travail médical destruction
mais effectivement je pense qu'on est on
a perdu on a perdu parce que quand vous
êtes à Marseille vous pouvez boire du
vin et vous allez en week-end à
Marrakech vous pouvez voir de fumer du
haschich vous rentrez vous boulevard du
vin on est où là dans cette je veux dire
la mondialisation des vices et les
plaisirs c'est un phénomène
incontournable ok il faut se protéger
adapter alors on va on va rester sur ce
thème là le thème de la dépénalisation
et de ce que rapporte effectivement un
point de deal on a ce chiffre qui est
donné par pas mal d'enquêteurs
finalement ils évaluent dit ça peut
rapporter un point de Deal jusqu'à 80
000 euros par jour par jour alors
effectivement quand on quand on est dans
un dans un quartier en plus où la
pauvreté est importante on imagine la
tentation un point de Deal Frédéric
flaubin ça peut faire vivre peut faire
vivre un quartier on parle vraiment
d'une économie parallèle quoi c'est une
évidence de dire ça mais je voudrais
qu'on le rappelle qu'on l'explique un
peu j'aime pas beaucoup l'idée que ça
fasse vivre un quartier parce que comme
vous le vous la dit tout à l'heure une
femme qui habite ses quartiers la
population est d'abord
otage oui autant les premiers bien sûr
mais en revanche ça fait vivre des clans
et des gangs oui et ben normalement
effectivement bon après les chiffres ils
sont ils sont variables ça peut aller de
25000 jours jusqu'à on a vu moi j'ai vu
des points deal monter à 120 125 130
jours donc ça c'est ça c'est une réalité
ça dépend la clientèle ça dépend où ils
sont placés et c'est vrai que c'est pour
ça qu'il y a une guerre sur le contrôle
de ces territoires parce qu'elle est
territoires qui rapportent beaucoup plus
que d'autres c'est pas très compliqué
savoir c'est la même chose en région
parisienne il suffit de d'une bouche de
métro il suffit d'une bretelle
d'autoroute il suffit d'une station RER
il suffit de choses comme ça pour tout
beaucoup survaloriser les endroits où il
y avait pas en région parisienne le
métro on l'a prolongé et là c'est
formidable il y a une manne qui arrive
comme ça pourquoi parce que la clientèle
la clientèle elle doit se déplacer enfin
jusqu'à présent c'est plus facile de
venir parce qu'ils sont en train
d'inventer autre chose et que bien sûr
qu'en fait ça ça rapproche les
consommateurs des points de vie
exactement enfin c'est l'effet pervers
connexes ce qui veut pas dire qu'il faut
pas des enclaver les quartiers mais non
mais je sais bien mais bon
mais alors effectivement ma formulation
elle était très maladroite je je je vais
le redire différemment quand il y a un
point de villes qui marche à ce
moment-là il y a combien de personnes
qui en vivent quoi ça peut être quoi ça
peut être des dizaines de personnes il y
a des petites mains il y a des quand
j'ai pas moi j'ai épluché plusieurs cas
de figure en général aujourd'hui vu la
pression policière dans dans Monsieur
sénateur tout à l'heure là qui est réel
en général le boss le patron il est pas
là il est pas sur le terrain il est
souvent à Dubaï il peut être à Marrakech
il est dans des endroits plus ou moins
tranquille pour lui ou il sait qu'il
sera pas extradé vers la France il peut
être il y avait un procès aujourd'hui à
Marseille
de gérer son ses points de vivre depuis
la prison
donc à partir de là c'est relativement
simple mais c'est aussi simple pour la
police de les coincer parce que quand
vous avez un téléphone en prison il est
vite localisé et la police vide vous
rapidement vous cerne donc vous avez
déjà le boss qui est là ensuite vous
avez sur place il délègue un chef de un
chef de territoire qui lui enfin donc le
boss met la pression est terrorise le
chef de territoire qui lui-même est sur
place qui lui-même recrute des petites
mains qui lui-même doit en permanence
faire avec un avec des petites mains qui
qui peuvent avoir peur qui peuvent ne
pas venir au boulot qui qui donc va
terroriser également ces second couteau
et ses petites mains qui sont en
première ligne dans la rue donc ça ça
peut ça peut très vite faire un groupe
humain de 20 30 30 personnes avec avec
une possibilité de renouveler en
permanence le personnel on parlait de
effectivement de moi je connais des
jeunes de la région parisienne il y a
pas très longtemps des Yvelines qui
avaient pas de boulot dans les points de
l'île localement et qui sont dit tiens
et qui se sont des qui sont partis à
Marseille alors les aînés du quartier
aussi de les dissuader mais ils sont
allés quand même parce que c'est la pas
puis vous savez aujourd'hui c'est
génération
ultra radicale c'est-à-dire génération
kalachnikov comme comme je l'appelle
elle va elle est utilisée normalement
les réseaux sociaux et donc ça va vous
paraître bizarre vous si vous êtes
demain criminel ou vous êtes délinquant
vous allez vous cacher alors eux pas du
tout c'est ce qui signifie d'ailleurs
qu'il y a une certaine impunité moi
quand je travaille sur eux ils viennent
se raconter ils viennent se parler ils
viennent ils viennent dire qu'ils sont
et ceux qui le font donc ils sont dans
la relative impunité attendez je finis
là-dessus et ils font la promotion et la
publicité de ce qu'ils font sur les
réseaux sociaux ça c'est une nouvelle
dimension qui signifie dans quel monde
enfin la police elle court après des
individus qui eux je dirais ils font
leur ils font leur job sans aucune
limite sans aucune capacité de
s'autoriser et en plus et en plus ils
affichent ce qu'ils font le jeune tueur
à gage
il a 18 ans il fait quasiment à Mohamed
Merah je veux dire un profil beaucoup
plus terroriste pour le pour le coup le
tueur de Toulouse qui avait tué en série
avec sa GoPro et qui voulait mettre en
scène ses ses actes comme si il
s'agissait d'actes héroïque donc ce
jeune là qui vient d'apparaître sur le
marché c'est nouveau lui il avait ce
besoin pour se justifier vis-à-vis de
ses patrons il fallait kiffer mais en
plus c'est d'utiliser cela je voilà
pardon nous interrompre je reprends la
malle c'était passionnant mais un petit
peu long quand même alors je voudrais
qu'on parle de la jeunesse
c'est votre c'est votre métier votre
salon vous avez effectivement cette
question de la jeunesse à la fois des de
certains tueurs et évidemment des des
victimes je vous propose un premier
témoignage sur ce thème là
militante du collectif des familles elle
s'appelle Zaïa Meziane collectif des
familles contre les violences c'était
lors d'une manifestation dans la cité du
du Castella deux jours avant réglement
de compte il y avait eu deux morts et
plusieurs blessés on l'écoute
faut que ça s'arrête ça devient c'est de
plus en plus violent quoi puis vous
rendez compte 14 ans 13 ans c'est des
bébés c'est des bébés faut faire quelque
chose pour pas qu'il tombe dans
l'engrenage de des réseaux il faut voilà
il faut les aider ces jeunes alors je me
tourne une première fois vers Fadela
widev qui est donc habitante des
quartiers Nord militantes associatifs
qui est avec nous au téléphone mais bon
vous avez brièvement dans le reportage
d'ouverture de ce débat et on a votre
photo pour bien vous vous incarnez vous
avez je crois des enfants adolescents
comment ça se passe voilà des enfants
adolescents les cloître pas dans
l'appartement donc vous vivez quoi avec
la peur qui reviennent pas racontez-nous
un peu cette peur au quotidien ok en
quelque sorte bonjour à tous
je veux bien parler des ados mais je
voulais juste revenir sur ce qui a été
dit précédemment j'ai pas pu intervenir
en fait c'était juste pour
remettre les choses dans le contexte
dans la réalité un point de Jean qui
tourne à 80 000 euros par jour il tourne
pas longtemps à 80.000 euros par jour
c'est énorme donc en fait c'est très
vite repéré par la police et c'est très
vite stoppé et revenir aussi sur la
question est-ce que un quartier peut
vivre d'un réseau jamais jamais les
habitants
c'était ma formulation qui était
maladroite donc on oublie cette
formulation ça ça peut arriver de de
d'employer les mauvais mots non mais je
vous repose la question des je vous
pardon c'est difficile quand on est au
téléphone mais effectivement la
formulation n'était pas bonne mais voilà
comment ça se passe même pour vous quoi
est-ce que chaque moto qui passe vous
fait peur quoi je voudrais juste
comprendre ce qui se passe clairement on
a peur de sortir on a peur de circuler
on a les ados qui sont en pleine qui
sont en plein dans leur crise et qui ne
ont les autorise pas à faire ce qu'ils
ont envie de faire alors qu'ils ont
envie de liberté ils ont pas ils peuvent
pas faire leur crise d'ado normal parce
que on a peur pour leur vie en fait
et ça c'est dramatique c'est dramatique
pour la jeunesse de d'être cloîtré à la
maison le plus possible par les parents
parce qu'on a peur qu'il fasse tirer
dessus c'est notre réalité dans le
reportage vous entendez parler d'une
prison à ciel ouvert voilà ce que vous
ressentez le
l'aggravation de depuis le début de
l'année ça veut dire quoi pour vous il y
a vraiment faites vraiment une
différence entre le début de cette année
2023 et ce qui se passait auparavant oui
oui ça fait un an et demi à peu près
deux ans maximum ou c'est vraiment la
violence elle est quotidienne et c'est
toute l'année avant ça c'était par
période en fait il y avait des phases
violentes et ça se calmer c'était des
règlements de compte entre gang entre
clans et quand ils avaient fait ce
qu'ils avaient à faire qu'à calmer mais
en fait maintenant c'est tout le temps
c'est tout le temps toute l'année donc
en fait on a peur tout le temps
je reviendrai vers vous plus tard dans
le débat fadelaides merci un de ceux de
ce témoignage janvier c'est vrai que
Marseille est souvent sous les
projecteurs médiatiques pour des fêtes
de violence depuis des années voire des
décennies est-ce que vous faites vous
aussi la différence entre ce qui se
passe là depuis depuis quelques mois et
les périodes précédentes qu'un cran
supplémentaire un degré supplémentaire a
été franchi ou pas tous les spécialistes
disent qu'il y a de grandes banques qui
s'affrontent moi je suis pas spécialiste
que ça mais donc il a l'air d'y avoir un
moment ce qui est vrai aussi si vous
voulez c'est que pour bien voir dans ces
quartiers c'est vrai que la vie et
devient assez impossible c'est vrai
aussi qu'il y a du travail au noir c'est
Raphaël l'économie parallèle la drogue
n'est qu'un élément d'un système qui
permet à des gens de vivre qui souvent
sont très modestes et très souvent ne
trouvent pas du boulot normal je veux
dire parce qu'ils ont pas la bonne
couleur de peau il faut dire les choses
comme elles sont parce que dans ces
quartiers un gamin qui s'est décarcassé
pour avoir des diplômes il a beaucoup
moins de chance d'avoir un boulot que le
mec des quartiers sud donc il faut dire
ça il faut dire aussi que c'est parce
que nos enfants consomment il y a 5
millions de consommateurs réguliers il y
a un moment si vous voulez c'est pas les
enfants des autres qui consomment j'ai
pas forcément tous les miens consomment
mais je veux dire c'est nos enfants
c'est à dire les enfants de toutes les
classes sociales
et les enfants mais il y a pas que les
enfants non mais quand je dis les
enfants et les jeunes ils commencent à
puis ils continuent alors il y a des
gens toute leur vie maintenant y compris
on sait la petite fumette entre copains
à 50 ans le soir le dimanche ça devient
presque un invariant comme un petit
biscuit donc vous êtes d'accord avec
Stéphane pour dire que il y a aussi la
responsabilité du consommateur c'est une
sorte de responsabilité collective quand
on fait la prohibition c'est parce qu'on
va interdire quelque chose que les gens
désirent on a essayé de la merde sur la
prostitution en disant maintenant bah
poursuivre le client bon le résultat
parce qu'il prenais la prostitution
parce qu'on supprime à jamais la
prostitution par contre qu'on contrôle
que ça se passe bien etc quand même il y
a le moins mal possible on va dire puis
il y a un côté de morale publique qui
vient trembler cette affaire moi ce qui
me suis posé les gens ça devient
inhabitable tous ces jeunes qui meurent
je suis désolé c'est un pur scandale il
y a des centaines de jeunes qui meurent
parce que une partie de la population
consomme de drogue et parce que tout
autour de chez nous il y en a donc ces
jeunes d'accord ils sont dealers j'ai
entendu des élus me dire ouais non mais
tant qui se tue entre eux quoi en
question entre c'est des gamins des
jeunes qui leur vie s'arrêtent bon il y
a tout ça qui joue regardez les nombres
de quartiers ou un certain moment on
avait demandé par exemple que les
tickets restaurants soient plus payés en
liquide au resto U ouais enfin la colle
et puis d'enfants donc j'ai dit faux
forts tout ça qui à certains endroits
donc voilà je crois qu'il faut dire ça
et qu'en ce moment il y a une forme
d'augmentation il y a l'air d'avoir une
tension particulière mais sur le fond il
y a un phénomène de fond qu'on ne fait
pas reculer alors et la jeunesse fume
plutôt un peu moins ça après les études
que j'ai vues les jeunes fument plutôt
un peu moins mais donc mais de manière
générale il fait moins de tabac etc j'ai
dans Danse à dire il peut-être aussi la
pandémie des arrêts récrécis voilà on
est dans cette situation ce que je ne
sais pas c'est quel est le sens du
combat et je vais vous dire une chose
j'aime pas quand la République est
ridiculisée moi je fais des tests à
Marseille je me déplaçais avec un jeune
devant les collèges je disais trop loin
dis-leur il fallait deux minutes moi je
j'ai pas les clés je sais pas mais lui
il savait parce qu'entre eux ils se
reconnaissent le mec et là qu'est-ce qui
donc un moment quand la République perd
la face c'est tragique pour ce qu'elle
symbolise or c'est ce qui nous arrive si
vous voulez au-delà des jeunes qui sont
tués depuis longtemps Émilie oui moi
j'ai l'impression que cette question
morale elle empêche de réfléchir et
d'aller au bout de la réflexion c'est
quand même assez hypocrite parce que
l'alcool franchement voilà l'alcool on
consomme de l'alcool on peut consommer
par l'alcool et par le tabac
d'hypocrisie parce qu'on est un pays du
vin de l'alcool donc on se dit ça c'est
pas très grave alors que le cannabis oh
là là alors que comme on le disait c'est
consommé partout chez tout le monde les
grands comme les petits et j'ai
l'impression que ça empêche de réfléchir
jusqu'au bout c'est-à-dire si on testait
cette légalisation ou dépénalisation si
on taxé par exemple comme on taxe le
tabac combien ça rapporterait parce
qu'il y a ça aussi tous ces trafics
c'est de l'argent en moins pour l'État
qu'est-ce que ça nous permettrait de
faire pour justement régulariser à ce
moment-là ce business l'améliorer en
termes de qualité donner des contraintes
peut-être des réglementations et puis
comme vous l'avez aussi des campagnes de
communication comme on le fait pour
l'alcool l'alcool c'est dangereux pour
la santé pourquoi on dirait pas le
cannabis et le shit c'est dangereux pour
la santé si vous en consommez voici les
règles du jeu mais on peut pas avancer
là-dessus parce qu'on est coincé par
cette espèce de tabou moral qu'on
n'arrive pas à dépasser à ces doubles
arguments sur l'hypothèse d'une
légalisation des pénalisation je vais
vous donner la parole là-dessus mais on
entend un habitant un autre habitant de
ce quartier de la cité du du cassella
même manifestation lui il dit ben
clairement essayons la légalisation
écoutez moi je pense qu'on est obligé de
passer par la légalisation ça j'en suis
convaincu et si on ne le fait pas comme
mettre une grave erreur mais comme on
est déjà intelligents
si
pendant la légalisation ne fonctionne
pas on reviendra en arrière tout
simplement voilà il y en a marre de voir
la police jouer à Don Quichotte at Tom
et Jerry je t'attrape je te lâche on se
suit on se poursuivre voilà mon point de
vue Stéphane on peut entendre cet
argument c'est-à-dire que ça fait la
prohibition ça marche pas 5 millions de
consommateurs en France donc faut
peut-être essayer autre chose déjà la
guerre contre le trafic de World c'est
une guerre d'usure c'est pas une guerre
éclair ça prendra le temps qu'il faudra
mais attention je dis simplement
attention aux messages qu'on m'a envoyé
on n'arrive pas à éradiquer le trafic de
cannabis donc on va l'égaliser mais
derrière ce sont les mêmes réseaux que
ça soit le cannabis ou la commune ou la
cocaïne ou la cocaïne il y a beaucoup le
problème le problème étant que si on
l'égalise ça veut dire qu'on donne un
blanc sans et la loi du plus fort a
gagné puisqu'on l'égalise donc à partir
de là
allez-y grandement vous pouvez consommer
du deuxième élément vous avez toujours
les notions de contrebande c'est comme
les cigarettes avec des produits qui
peuvent être plus ou moins dangereux
parce que pas aussi bien dosé que
qu'est-ce qu'on propose comme produit
légal comment les doser à quel prix il
est proposé pour que pour limiter le
risque de contrebande clairement qu'on a
pas tout essayé
vis-à-vis du trafic de drogue le chômage
non on n'a pas tout essayé les moyens
sont en train d'être mis sur Marseille
quoi comme en dise je suis désolé 300
policiers ça fait depuis un an même pas
qui sont en train d'être déployés le
système judiciaire là aussi le ministre
de l'Intérieur l'a très bien dit notre
arsenal législatif n'est pas encore au
point notamment pour écouter les
communications sur les réseaux snapchat
ou autre puisque c'est les
communications cryptées et on n'a pas le
droit de visions différentes vous dites
plus de répression c'est un plan global
et vous dites vis-à-vis
que l'on fait donc c'est pas comme si on
tombait de rien le Portugal a fait
baisser beaucoup la consommation le
Canada a une politique différente mais
intelligente c'est-à-dire ils ont dit on
va prendre les dealers et on va leur
dire c'est toi qui va avoir le bureau de
vente de drogue dans ton immeuble parce
que le problème c'est comment
diffuse l'argent dans le quartier parce
que actuellement il va où argent
réaliste et milliards ils vont
essentiellement acheter des commerces et
des stations services en Algérie ou au
Maghreb pour une partie c'est un métier
très dangereux mais si on gagne le
jackpot on part avec le pognon et on
rentre au pays c'est souvent ça qui se
passe pour dire les choses il comme
elles sont donc sur un moment et en plus
ça donne un rejet de la communauté émiré
parce qu'il y a une association entre
immigré drogue donc dans notre
imaginaire et ce qui est pas faux en
plus d'ailleurs il y avait une étude de
Darius qui était très intéressante sur
les plages il disait dès qu'il y a un
type qui est un look arabe qui est assis
en maillot de bain l'été toutes les deux
minutes il y a un type qui a demandé tu
vendu h c'est-à-dire que c'est comme il
disait c'est comme un truc de pharmacie
qui clignote très vert donc je veux dire
faut pas se cacher derrière ces réalités
et le renforcement du racisme porté par
tout ça je pense voilà après je suis pas
un adepte comme ça mais je pense que les
pays qui l'ont tenté ont fait diminuer
la consommation l'Allemagne en train d'y
réfléchir sur un modèle associatif donc
tout le monde réfléchit sauf nous on ne
parle que sécurité et ça ne marche pas
si ça marche attendez je le preneur ou
le premier c'est pas la tendu des
arguments je vais parce qu'il y a encore
plein de thèmes à aborder j'aurais quand
même vous poser une question
en fait si imaginons qu'on qu'on
légalise le trafic de cannabis est-ce
que pour autant il y aurait plus de
points de Deal enfin il peut y avoir des
points deal des guerres de territoire
sur de sur les autres drogues interdites
vous voyez ce que je veux dire je pense
que les dealers sont plus malin que
l'État que l'État dealer sera moins bon
commerçant que les dealers eux-mêmes
donc on peut toujours essayer moi je
pourquoi pas après il faut politiquement
une majorité qui l'assume mais je suis
absolument convaincu de choses c'est que
ils vont sont des bons commerçants faut
pas l'oublier donc ils vont vous
proposer un produit de meilleure qualité
que l'État ne peut pas vendre parce que
l'État ne peut vendre que des produits
qui se fument avec un taux de THC pas
trop élevé donc ils dire ok l'état elle
va limiter le THC parce que quand même
l'état dealer peut pas se mettre à
vendre un cannabis et une herbe qui sont
trop puissantes d'accord donc ils vont
cultiver des produits beaucoup plus
forts mais bon ça j'anticipe un petit
peu je connais bien le crime organisé le
crime organisé hyper réactif hyper
souple s'adapta tout il inventera ils
vont ils vont proposer des produits plus
forts ils vont proposer l'État ne pourra
jamais vendre au mineur l'État va être
obligé de gérer mettons que ce soit
demain dans les dans les bureaux de
tabac on dit au patron au bureau de
tabac maintenant vous allez vendre du
shit et de là ok mais vous allez pas le
vendre mineur dont vous demandez la
carte d'identité ok d'accord moins de 18
ans vous vendez pas alors déjà ça fait
un double marché ça fait un marché pour
ceux qui veulent du produit fort ça fait
un marché pour ceux qui veulent vendre
mineur et je vous assure qu'ils vont pas
gérer ça leur pose aucun problème de ce
côté là et ensuite parallèlement
effectivement faut pas oublier
qu'aujourd'hui en France le principal
fléau c'est pas tellement l'air Belgique
c'est pas tellement ça c'est qu'il y a
un espèce de tsunami de cocaïne qui a
démarré il y a
5 6 ans et que alors là pour le coup
jamais on verra un état où que ce soit
dans le monde commencer à penser et
attendez une troisième drogue qui
remonte en puissance aujourd'hui sur le
territoire que moi je constate y compris
dans les zones rurales parce qu'il y a
pas qu'à Marseille qu'on consomme de la
drogue non justement c'est pour ça que
pour la police est compliquée c'est
qu'il y a une multiplication des fronts
il y a pas un front il y a les fronts
absolument partout donc c'est l'héroïne
et l'héroïne aujourd'hui revient
également et là je vois pas non plus à
quelconque est allé dans le monde
légaliser ça c'est fait avec la régie
autrefois de l'opium ça c'est fait au
tout début quand il y avait 600
toxicomanes en France et pas et pas 5
millions il y avait une régie et c'était
l'État qui vendait l'opium donc on a
testé déjà ça ça c'est fait ok
c'est très intéressant
vous lirez réagir sur l'égalisation des
pénalisation ou pas
avec un gros travail oui je pense que au
final on arrivera à la dépénalisation et
la légalisation c'est évident puisque
quand on voit le nombre de clients par
jour qui qui va acheter il y a pas que
les consommateurs du secteur il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de belles voitures qui
viennent qui viennent se pourrir dans
les quartiers donc moi je pense que ça
va arriver un jour après je pense pas
que ça soit la seule solution parce que
les endroits où il y a ces points de
Jean les quartiers populaires dans toute
la France pas qu'à Marseille il y a une
misère sociale il y a beaucoup de 40 il
y a beaucoup de décrochage scolaires
donc il y a un travail de fond à faire
sur ça parce que les jeunes qui sont
happés par les réseaux
c'est les jeunes qui ont une carotte une
tarte ou des familles monoparentales ou
des parents au chômage il y a toujours
quelque chose qui manque et ils vont le
trouver en bas dans le réseau et c'est
comme ça qu'ils sont à pattés en fait
les gens des réseaux maintenant ils sont
très bien formés pour trouver les
maillons faible et hop les happer
vous posiez la question de finalement de
des moyens des politiques publiques on
va justement en parler tout de suite
avec avec Quentin Calmet rebonsoir
Quentin puisque on s'en souvient vous
l'avez évoqué monsieur le sénateur le
chef de l'État s'était rendu à Marseille
c'était en septembre 2021 pour présenter
un plan d'aide à la ville exactement et
en ce mois de septembre 2021 on est
alors au lendemain on était terrible
marqué déjà par une douzaine de
règlements de comptes liés au trafic de
stupéfiants mais le Macron se rend à la
cité phocéenne pendant deux jours et
demi pour présenter le plan Marseillan
grand c'était alors la plus longue
visite du chef de l'État depuis le début
de son quinquennat on retient un des
mesures en faveur d'éducation des
transports mais aussi en matière de
sécurité d'ailleurs la première étape
est symbolique une déambulation dans les
quartiers nord de la ville puis dans le
commissariat du 15e arrondissement c'est
les images que vous voyez à l'instant le
programme public assure alors ne pas
être venu pour faire de fausses
promesses dit-il mais selon lui la
réponse est aussi sécuritaire il faut
démanteler les réseaux écouter le chef
de l'État à peu près
[Musique]
200 arrivées pour l'année
d'accélérer les choses voilà les
syndicats de policiers qui salue les
annonces à l'époque mais déjà qui assure
que les policiers seuls n'y arriveront
pas et d'ailleurs le deuxième jour de
cette visite il y a un plan plus large
présenté appelé Marseille en grand voilà
avec au total environ un milliard et
demi d'euros de financement de nouveau
pour les transports la culture la
rénovation des écoles il parle alors
d'une ville pleine d'énergie qui veut se
libérer de ces fractures écouter à
nouveau le camp de la République
j'assume complètement que le devoir de
la nation et d'être aux côtés des
marseillaises et des Marseillais
parce que décider que ce serait une
ville comme les autres ce serait acté
qu'elle va continuer à vivre au milieu
de ces difficultés les subir
et ne pas réussir pour elle-même pour
tout le territoire et pour tout le pays
c'est qu'elle ne pourra pas jouer le
rôle
doit jouer dans cette Méditerranée à
laquelle je crois profondément et donc
je pense que aider aujourd'hui Marseille
a réussi
c'est aider à déclencher quelque chose
qui est là
mais c'est bon pour le pays tout entier
voilà pour cet extrait de la déclaration
d'Emmanuel Macron quand il faut quand
même rappeler que des plans pour
Marseille il y en a eu d'autres on a
cherché les archives depuis que c'est
normal on a retrouvé pas mal en fait
déjà il y a eu par exemple 2015 ou
manuel Valls se promettait 30 millions
d'euros pour le développement de la
ville en 2012 Jean Marc Ayrault partait
en immersion dans la ville tiens tiens
déjà après un comité interministériel
qui lui se tenait à Matignon écoutez le
Premier ministre alors qui promet en
septembre 2012 la fin de l'inertie à
Marseille il était accompagné je crois
de 18 de 18 ministres sur cette image à
ce moment-là c'est aussi les règlements
de comptes qui gangrène la ville et on
parle déjà de l'envoi de renfort de
policier écoutez Jean-Marc ayant
gouvernement est déterminé a contribuer
à relever le défi du redressement
économique social école écologique et
culturelle pour Marseille pour ça il
faut sortir des paralysies des jeux
personnel pour mobiliser tous les
acteurs politiques économiques sociaux
universitaires culturelle pour engager
concrètement la décision du gouvernement
de créer ici pour l'avenir des habitants
une métropole puissante voilà on le voit
c'est presque un exercice en soi pour
l'exécutif d'annoncer des plans pour
Marseille merci Quentin Stefano de Lille
les archives elles sont souvent
douloureuses on va dire pour pour les
les hommes et les femmes politiques mais
moi je retiens déjà Manuel Valls 2015 30
millions d'euros Emmanuel Macron
septembre 21 plus d'un milliard presque
on l'a dit c'est pas seulement une
question d'argent mais quand même là
depuis 20 mois il y a un plan qui est
autrement plus ambitieux que les
précédents en tout cas c'est
l'impression qu'on a
vous nous dites que la guerre
d'aujourd'hui elle est presque liée au
coup de pied qui a été donné dans la
fourmilière par le les renforts
policiers en tout cas les renforts
policiers et la stratégie de
déstabilisation des réseaux à amener une
recrudescence de la violence et des
conquêtes de territoires à effectivement
d'après ce qu'on sait il y a deux clans
qui qui s'affrontent et d'où ces
règlements de comptes successifs
maintenant sur les investissements il
faut être très précis c'est 256 millions
de subventions de l'État et 750 millions
d'avance donc oui ça fait un milliard au
total mais les 750 millions d'avance
sont bien des collectivités comme la
métropole Aix-Marseille Provence ou la
mairie de Marseille qui vont en fait
devoir après rembourser à terme de 50
c'est 750 millions mais alors ok mais ça
par exemple il va sur quoi sur les les
services publics les transports la
mobilité on a un gros souci de mobilité
sur sur Marseille
et ça c'est de
250 millions vous savez le budget
mobilité de la métropole avec le plan
grand Marseille c'est 200 millions
d'investissements et de fonctionnement
par an c'est énorme mais on a besoin de
se rattrapage il y a deux lignes de
métro sur sur Marseille regardez par
rapport à comparer à Paris vous avez des
transports en commun qui sont encore une
fois à optimiser vos regardez Marseille
le matin et l'engorgement pour arriver
dans la deuxième ville de France parce
que en fait on a deux axes autoroutiers
mais avec des voies très très réduites
donc il faut repenser mobilité pour
désenclaver certains certains quartiers
puis le deuxième axe sont les écoles il
y avait un grand plan sur les groupes
scolaires que doit porter porter la
mairie pour réinvestir au niveau des des
écoles et les moderniser pour qu'il y a
un cadre d'apprentissage digne digne de
ce nom mais là encore pour l'heure c'est
aux collectivité derrière de réaliser
ces grands investissements il y a une
annonce de la part de l'État et c'est
donc à la mairie nécropole est-ce que ça
peut marcher cette fois-ci alors pour
l'instant on n'en voit pas voilà
la ville va beaucoup mieux c'est pour
faire attention je veux dire parce que
là c'est vrai que la drogue les crimes
c'est potable mais je prenait un seul
indicateur depuis la pandémie la moyenne
de hausse du foncier ben Montpellier par
exemple c'est 7 % Marseille c'est 14 %.
c'est à dire que la ville est devenue
extrêmement
parce que vous avez énormément de jeunes
hyper diplômés qui viennent habiter à
Marseille pour le mode il y a 32 km de
rivage quand même se représenter ce que
c'est Marseille au-delà du fait que
c'est beau etc et c'est les problèmes de
transport c'est aussi une ville qui fait
32 km de large avec seulement moins
d'amis en habitants dans la ville même
donc forcément les problèmes de
connexion sont très complexes mais la
ville se développe mais effectivement
depuis qu'on a fait marcher capital
européenne de la culture on a transformé
le vieux port on en a fait une zone bon
et cetera il y a une vie culturelle
c'est une très grande ville touristique
ce qui était absolument pas le cas qui
avait l'idée d'aller en weekend à
Marseille maintenant ça se développe
vous avez le développement des startups
vous avez le port qui a repris une
fonction économique importante c'est
pour ça qu'il faut faire attention
Marseille est en train de sortir de
l'ornière où elle était en gros depuis
la guerre d'Algérie pour le match
comment faire en sorte que ces quartiers
dont on parle depuis le début ben il
soit dans le bon wagon quoi vous voyez
200000 habitants dans ces quartiers et
c'est le cœur populaire de 7 métropole
on a construit le métropole on s'est
battu je ne sais pas mais enfin je pense
quand c'était tous pour en tout cas pour
créer une grande métropole se dire il y
a une métropole en gros de presque 2
millions et demi d'habitants bon il
comprend Aix les temps de Berre etc les
quartiers populaires ils sont au centre
de la métropole parce qu'on peut aller à
Aix on peut aller à l'étang de merde etc
c'est aussi pour ça que la question des
transports elle est importante comment
ces gens-là quand ils veulent aller à
Berre ils doivent pas d'abord au
centre-ville de Marseille repartir de
l'autre côté etc donc il y a tous ces
enclavagements etc donc on est il faut
faire attention il y a une phase
positive mais effectivement ces
quartiers appris à des problèmes d'école
il y a des problèmes de sécurité des
problèmes de logement il y a énormément
de femmes seules avec enfants ce sont
des quartiers qui sont déstructurés par
ces modes de vie mais on peut voir les
chiffres de la de la pauvreté d'ailleurs
les seuil de pauvreté alors à Marseille
26% de la population qui vit sous ce
seuil de pauvreté qui est à 940 euros
par mois et alors si on va dans le dans
les quartiers dont on parle c'est 52% et
bien sûr alors que la moyenne nationale
c'est 7000 ans depuis la guerre dans ces
quartiers parce qu'on s'est dit comme ça
en gros tantôt c'était les communistes
qui disaient à grande et c'est du
populaire ils vont voter pour nous
c'était le 16 secteur communiste la
ville avait été découpée politiquement
on va dire avec une astuce on pourrait
dire de manière totalement qui
démocratique par les mairies successives
ça fait rire mais à un moment les
communistes ont été le premier parti de
la ville n'avait qu'un secteur sur sept
grâce à des découpements astucieux donc
du coup on a concentré le HLM là à un
moment si vous avez que des HLM ou
perdez ce qui fait une partie de
l'économie urbaine c'est les services
les garagistes les services de ménage
etc si vous mettez tous les pots au même
endroit comment vous faites société
ensemble c'est pour ça qu'un véritable
enjeu d'aménagement du territoire il est
temps de s'y mettre la mobilité mais
également le logement je veux pas vous
attaquer politiquement aujourd'hui mais
enfin il est clair qu'on a une mairie
qui était là très très longtemps le
résultat est pas proprement mais enfin
c'est pas le sujet mais il y a un deuil
long mais j'ai décidé
sur sur l'ancien maire de Marseille pour
l'instant monsieur Payan est aux
commandes attendons qu'il va tout
changer je n'ai pas de problème par
rapport non mais par rapport au million
d'euros voir un milliard annoncé
effectivement la mairie a une
responsabilité notamment sur la
modernisation des écoles à lancer les
travaux et sur le logement le travail en
phase avec la métropole un dernier thème
parce qu'il y a une personnalité du
gouvernement qui est en première ligne
sur sur ces questions c'est évidemment
le ministre de l'Intérieur il a
rapidement mis en avant les moyens
déployés par l'État oui après tous ces
règlements de comptes il a rappelé les
moyens dont vous parliez d'ailleurs tout
à l'heure renforcement des effectifs de
police plus de 300 renforts de la
filière judiciaire une vingtaine
d'enquêteurs en plus la chasse aux
dealer avec la multiplication des
contrôles des points de Deal donc tout
un tas de mesures alors loin de moi de
penser l'idée que le sujet est simple je
pense qu'on
mais cette communication exacerbée est
habituelle chez Gérald Darmanin pour lui
le principe de l'hyper présence du
premier flic de France qui avait été
établi avant lui par Nicolas Sarkozy et
bien c'est un incontournable il faut
être partout tout le temps à chaque fois
qu'il se passe quelque chose avec une
stratégie claire communiquer sur les
objectifs et les moyens et beaucoup
moins sur les résultats car de ce côté
c'est plus difficile pour le ministre
d'afficher des victoires on peut dire
même que c'est un petit peu l'inverse
ces derniers temps il multiplie les
échecs et c'est d'ailleurs bizarre parce
que ça ne déccorde pas son image ah oui
ça on va en parler pourquoi des vous
dites des échecs pourquoi quelle rapide
tour de piste le fiasco du Stade de
France me souviens la Ligue des
Champions avec quelques déclarations
erronées pour s'en sortir les
dissolutions avortées d'associations
comme Palestine vaincra plus récemment
soulèvement de la terre l'arrestation
impossible de l'imam eikes
l'interdiction des manifestations
d'ultra-droites qui arrivent tardivement
mais qui sont retoqués par la justice le
fiasco de l'opération lancé à Mayotte
qui reprend pour déplacer les immigrés
illégaux bon j'arrête là sans compter
son projet de loi immigration qui est
lancé depuis l'an dernier et qu'il peine
à faire avancer et sans parler aussi de
ses retours sur les positions qui
tenaient avant sur le mariage pour tous
notamment quand il était alléché par un
poste de Premier ministre alors la
spécialiste en communication de
politique que vous êtes sur le fait
qu'il reste aussi soutenu et bien il
faut croire que ça notoriété et plus
importantes aussi sont franc-parler et
il avait traité
Marine Le Pen de trop molle sur le thème
de l'immigration sa vision dure de tous
ces sujets régaliens peut-être que c'est
un atout pour ce gouvernement qui manque
de figure et pour un Emmanuel Macron qui
parfois a du mal à avancer sur ces
sujets là ou en tout cas avoir ce
discours aussi dur moi j'ai juste une
petite crainte sur ce mode de
fonctionnement et de communication on
arrive au moment de l'organisation des
Jeux Olympiques et d'ailleurs ce matin
encore Gérald Darmanin était dans cet
exercice de communication sur l'aspect
sécurité on sait qu'il y a des enjeux
énormes de ce côté là donc là pour le
coup un peu moins de communication plus
de résultats parce que il faut vraiment
pas se louper évidemment on l'espère
est-ce que vous êtes aussi dur sur le
bilan du ministre de l'Intérieur si on
reprend les cas d'espèces pourtant je
suis républicain mais attention c'est la
justice qui a cassé les décrets ou les
arrêter préfectaux
quand même 39 enfin il y a eu 300
policiers supplémentaires il y a eu 39
points de deal de démanteler je dis pas
que c'est c'est des résultats hyper
hyper positifs mais il faut aussi
laisser le temps à ce que la politique
mise en oeuvre par le gouvernement
puisse prendre en tout cas sur le
domaine de la sécurité en revanche là où
je suis beaucoup plus critique et je le
dis dès le départ de mon propos c'est
sur la chaîne pénale et donc le ministre
de la Justice qui malheureusement ne
suit pas les prérogatives du ministre de
l'Intérieur dans certains sur certains
aspects je partais des durcissements des
peines notamment pour pour les dealers
ou les têtes de réseau ou l'effectivité
des peines combien de dealers ressortent
avec des bracelets électroniques alors
que c'est des multirécidivistes il y a
quand même des questions à se poser à ce
niveau là et là c'était pas dans le
domaine du ministre de l'intérieur mais
plutôt le domaine du ministère
peut-être pour parce qu'on a fait là ce
focus sur Marseille
c'est presque à Marseille est sur ces
questions de guerre de dealer etc c'est
toujours sous les projecteurs
médiatiques c'est pas la seule la
marseille est une ville pionnier en
matière de grands banditisme c'est là où
tout a commencé c'est là où les liaisons
dangereuses entre la classe politique et
le gourmandisme ce sont doués c'est là
où la le commerce international de la
drogue a été inventé avec la French
Connection et l'héroïne donc moi j'ai
envie de dire attention parce que ce qui
se passe à Marseille en général
finissent par se passer ailleurs dans
l'Exode dans l'Hexagone en termes de
criminalité donc c'est une espèce de
modèle c'est là où c'est le laboratoire
de la criminalité contemporaine
française Marseille donc ce qui est en
train de se passer avec l'apparition de
turingage avec avec cet ultra violence
de jeunes qui bon qui s'éliminent avec
une haine féroce la haine la haine elle
existait déjà autant de Jack et le match
je veux dire quand à l'époque je veux
dire de Jacky de maths donc dans les
années 70-80 il y en a qui poursuivait
ce qu'il voulait assassiner pendant 20
ans donc cette vente d'État elle fait
partie de l'histoire mais je dis
attention parce que voilà ce qui est en
train de se passer en termes de
radicalisation risque de se propager
ailleurs sur le territoire merci
beaucoup merci à tous ici en plateau ou
au téléphone ça dès la weedf merci
d'avoir participé à cette émission je
rappelle l'étude de vos livres janvier
Marseille le réveil violent d'une ville
impossible c'est aux Éditions de l'Aube
et puis vous l'avez évoqué Frédéric
Loker Jacky le Mat livre coécrit avec
Christine Humbert et qui est donc publié
aux éditions plomb et la veuve ah bah
voilà je ne le savais pas donc voilà une
bonne information c'était important de
le dire la veuve de Jacky le Mat merci
pour pour l'information je vous dis à
demain vous pouvez également retrouver
nos programmes
l'émission Tous les programmes de la
chaîne sur la plateforme public sénat.fr
et puis notez votre prochain rendez-vous
politique Charlotte cobel la secrétaire
d'État chargé de l'enfance qui sera
l'invité Dorian Mancini c'est dans la
matinale de Public Sénat belle soirée
[Musique]